[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he's the star of the cincinnati reds a
six-time all-star won the mvp
back in 2010. he's joey votto who made
some news recently homering in
seven consecutive games i uh i i thought
that that tied the record
and uh i was since reminded that uh ken
griffey jr had
eight consecutive games don mattingly
eight and uh dale long
and joey vado joins us on the program
good to have you back joey did you know
what the record was
with uh consecutive games with a home
run i knew after uh game three
i was locked in on the record from game
three every single day i was thinking
about hitting a home run
really no no no no it wasn't until about
game six
i can't imagine you would be going yeah
i'm i'm sitting dead red i'm gonna hit a
home run tonight
oh yeah well i do think that often but
uh no at about game six i was flooded
with uh
are you gonna do it you know what we
were in new york city
uh playing against the mets and i'd
never experienced so much attention
before
um not only from fans on the street i'd
be in the back of an uber
and new york fans or people in new york
were telling me
joey you're gonna hit the seventh one
tonight or joe you're gonna hit the
eighth one tonight
and um but the people at the stadium
were crazy too i mean every
everybody i crossed paths with was
telling me come on man you can do it
tonight give it to us tonight so it was
it was
wonderful to feel that support do you
change anything
in what way your approach your advance
that
you know hey i got a chance to do
something really yeah like like game
seven
yeah or game eight like you you're going
up there going if i hit my eighth i'm
like i'm in there with some pretty good
you know company mattingly and ken
griffey jr well i have mattingly uh don
mattingly and
ken griffey jr's number i didn't know
until
a couple days before that dale long had
had hit eight in a row i was thinking
about sending out like a group
text when when i got to game eight like
just a little winky
winky emoji or something like that like
i'm coming for you
you know it was yours now it's mine sort
of thing but no i
um every every day every every bat i was
thinking about homering i wanted that
sucker so badly
about and you missed by a couple inches
with uh an eighth consecutive game
yeah story of my life
[Laughter]
by the way i didn't know that you were
dub the most interesting man in baseball
did who dubbed you the most interesting
man in baby no
nobody nobody i mean i think it was it
was an article
uh i don't drink so you know it's not a
dos equis thing but no i
i don't uh i wouldn't consider myself
that at all do you have to be
sociable at first base as a first
baseman
you have to be unless unless the pla
unless the hitter
unless it's the opposing pitcher or
unless the the batter got on by air then
you don't be sociable
then you got to stay mom but uh yeah
they
if somebody gets to first base usually
it's a good good thing for them
walk base hit some sort of stinging line
drive
you have to compliment them so the
answer is you got to be sociable you got
to
you got to compliment them and then roll
from there now now people get to first
base and they ask for loans so you can't
be too
friendly you can't be too friendly at
first but
like clayton kershaw if he got to first
base no conversation
well no a couple years ago he got to
first base clayton's very friendly and
you know you're pretty gonna be pretty
friendly when you're the best pitcher
every year so
you know he got to first base and there
was a pitch i took that was a
probably a fringe strike and he said it
ended up being ball four and he said
what'd you think about that pitch and i
said it was a strike and he said i
thought so too
you know that's that's the maximum of
our conversations when it comes to ball
on at first base
but do you talk to rookies at all of
course
of course you know i'm usually trying to
learn a thing or two from them i know it
sounds silly but i feel like i've
learned so much
over the past couple years from from the
younger generation so the answer is
absolutely yes
we had a debate the other day and two of
my guys here
so i had uh my producer paulie picked
aside
and he wanted your career as a future
hall of famer and then mclovin who's a
philadelphia phillies apologist
took bryce harper so that was the debate
yeah
yeah well i mean bryce is one of my
favorite players i mean i
he's he's he's going to be a special
player and uh
you know but uh do you think you're a
hall of famer
do i think i am i have you done enough
probably not yet no i you know i think
they've
i've heard that you have to get to at
least 2 000 hits
and i haven't gotten there yet so i
don't think i'm there
yet no uh well i think it ended where
we made some really strong points for
you
it was just bryce is i think is 10 years
younger than you so
yeah i'm assuming he's going to add to
his totals there joey
yeah yeah well i mean yeah yeah i've got
10 years
of salary accrued before you know he's
i've collected a lot more money than he
has but
he'll be okay he'll be just fine yeah
yeah i know
how is baseball different than when you
started
what was that oh seven you started
slower it's slower
um the the the players are better the
game is faster
we're more we're just better in general
but the game has gotten a little bit
slower
and i think that's i don't know exactly
why you know more walks more strikeouts
the athletes are better it's it's i
don't i guess you're not asking if it's
better or worse how is it different it's
just
it's just a little bit slower i remember
getting games done
in about two hours and 45 minutes two
hours and 55 minutes and now it's you
know 305
315. more home runs for sure more
strikeouts
uh the pitchers are tougher so much
tougher i mean when i came up
a guy coming out of the bullpen throwing
95 was throwing
petrol you know and and now if he's
throwing 105 you're thinking to yourself
okay this guy's throwing really hard so
that's probably the that's probably the
biggest difference
but but you're a throwback though
because you're you're a batting average
guy like you
you believe in putting the bat on the
ball and not hey i either hit a home run
or i strike out
would you be different now if you were
coming up where it's
either it's all or nothing no dan
i am all in on all or nothing i am home
runs in strikeouts now
that's what i'm about now that's hence
the
hence the nine home runs you know nine
straight games that was my goal
yeah so bat 230 and hit 40 bombs you're
good with that
no question no question about it that's
where my head's at now
who's the pitcher you faced where you
went i have absolutely no chance
let me tell you a good story so in 2008
uh dusty baker was the team's manager
and it was my birthday september 10th
and we were in milwaukee and dusty said
the day before september 9th he said you
got a day
off i want you to take it easy and it
was a night game day game
and he said take it easy and cc was
pitching cece sabathia's pitching
and uh i said no dusty
i want in there and dusty was is is like
that you know he's
he's he's he's the type of man who says
all right man all right get on out there
so the next day i i bat against cece's
bathia in the shadows in milwaukee i go
for four with four strikeouts
and cece without question
was the toughest pitcher at the time in
the league as a left-handed batter
most dominant i go up to dusty after
dusty approaches me after the game he
says
how'd you like that and i go oh man that
was tough that was tough next time
listen to me okay
but there have to be those moments and
guys talk about facing randy johnson or
i mean i like degrom do you ever feel
like what am i doing up here against the
ground
no i like i i like facing jacob um
there's some there's there's some tough
ones out there i mean of course jacob's
amongst that but i i don't get to face
him a ton
and um but would you rather face a
hundred
or a guy who had a lot of movement
nowadays you get so used to guys
throwing hard um
[Music]
i don't know it's hard to explain i i
don't know if there's a lot of movement
or
a hard thing that makes the difference
it's more about the match-up you know i
grew i came into league i face maddox i
face randy johnson i face
tom glavin you know but i've also faced
gerald's chapman i've also faced jacob
degrom so
it's more about the the matchup cece
going back to ccc bath
he was throwing really hard but then
he'd also hit you
you know he'd hit you without caring and
then and then and then spot up
three three three separate pitches so
you know
it's it's all about the matchups we're
talking to joey votto the cincinnati
reds uh first baseman turns 38 in
september
i didn't know you were a huge basketball
fan
big basketball fan i i i
took a little bit of pause i won't get
into specifics why i took a pause but
there were some players that moved to
specific teams that i felt like
really ruined the league for a second
and now that giannis owns the league now
that it like an
a player organically comes from the same
organization
and uh so when kawaii left toronto
oh boy how did that hurt
i i didn't like that he left the spurs
i don't like when the thunder got broken
up i don't like i'm
i guess i'm a bit of a throwback jordan
was my guy
as a as a teen as a younger person uh
staying with the same organization is
something i'm very fond of i mean
uh so this is a topic i have to
watch what i say uh but but you're
you grew up a toronto fan like that's
right
vince carter yeah that hurt that hurt
kills me when they give him an ovation i
get it i get it
i get it but um so and you also played
basketball didn't you a little bit in
high school i'm i'm nothing special
i have a teammate that actually played
division one college basketball me or
garrett so
i'm not gonna make any claims here i all
i know is i got stats that you
once dropped 37 points against your
bitter rivals
[Laughter]
is that true i don't i don't remember i
don't remember i don't remember what i
did in last night's baseball game so i'm
not sure
you went over four i think last night
no is there is there uh a a school
collegiate
yeah yeah we call our high schools
collegiates up there
up in toronto canada it's uh
uh e-t-o-b-i-c-o-k-e
yeah you yeah tobacco oh you don't spell
it coke
yeah so you put up 37 against them did i
really
yeah yeah okay yeah good for good for
17-year-old me
um the gold star skyline do you get
involved in that the
i mean ah um cincinnati
specific uh i i i've never been to
skyline
and every time i say that i get booed so
i
hopefully there's not too much of a
cincinnati contingent in your in your uh
following but um there will be no there
will be no
no no no skyline for me yeah what about
a gold star
no never gold star i go home listen i go
home
i eat celery i eat
no low-fat low-fat yogurt and then i get
a good night's rest
and uh i run it back there's no uh
there's no there's no
skyline chili for me my friend there's
no stories here there's like
you're you're the most boring guy in
baseball not the most interesting
exactly but that's by design that's by
design that's by design but
you know um yeah i gotta i uh yeah
not that i'm gonna cloud your head with
this but when you go to the plate
maybe a home run i mean is that asking
too much
no that's not asking too much today will
be a day
where i think about hitting a home run
because of dan patrick so thank you
yep and and when you do it just say in
the post game
i did that for cincinnati native dan
patrick that's perfect
yeah i love it yes yeah and if you don't
i'll be here you're from cincinnati
mason are you really yeah i don't know
that yeah i grew up
yes yeah why don't you google me joey i
googled you before you came on
yeah but you're interviewing me i'm not
interviewing you this could be a
conversation
i was actually funny enough i was
actually listening to previous uh
the best of dan patrick's on my way into
work just to figure out what kind of
rhythm
turns out you're very sarcastic very dry
it turns out you and your you and your
group give each other a hard time they
were talking about your plum
pants one time yeah it was a best of
yeah best stuff yeah
that's a cincinnati kind of tone so i
mean i fit in
yeah i got guys who are good clubhouse
guys yeah you do like they're not good
on the field
but you know their guys mendoza line
stuff but
but i like them like that's my goal in
the next few years that's my goal you
think
no you can't go like you're a three what
315 career hitter or something like that
aren't you
i'm doing i'm doing fine i don't know if
it's quite that it's hard in this league
to hit for a high average
that's okay like 272 this year that's
yeah now you're right
get it going dan i'll get it going
um it's always great to talk to you and
uh once again we have your back when it
comes to the hall of fame
well most of us do one one guy still has
bryce harper but uh
you know we're we're betting on you joey
well it's not an either or
both of us you know oh it's okay well i
mean i'm not saying
whether it happens or not it's kind of
irrelevant there's more than one
that can join so bryce is probably going
to be one and if i'm not then
you failed in your argument so that's
true it's totally fine uh and by the way
when can we do we move on from the
astros
booing can yeah yeah and
uh yeah there's no question about it the
idea that they were the only one doing
something wrong
just baffles me but i you know
i agree with you completely but if
altuve gets to first base
yes very fond of him i like him a lot
what kind of conversation do you have
i've had lots of conversations with him
we talk about hitting almost entirely
but no
garbage can no no garbage can mentions
like you can't even have a little subtle
dig can you
no cause he came out and said that
listen he came out and said
that he had no part in it and i i have
to believe a person
based on you know if they i'm assuming
he's telling the truth so i'm going to
believe him and then we move on from
there
you know hypothetically if you knew
if you knew what the pitch was ooh how
would you do
if i said fastball
yeah i'd still be hitting home runs we'd
be a game 10 right now
oh you'd have 10 consecutive home runs
there's
if i knew what was coming yes yeah i'd
be on rba game 10 by now but some guys
don't want to know i don't want to know
because i don't want to cheat
so if somebody's at second base and and
they could signal in
where you know where the location i mean
i i don't let me phrase that correctly
if i if someone were to like if there
was a tip from the pitcher i would want
to know
but as far as like you know
as far as like any sort of like
complicated cheating strategy no i'm i'm
not for that
but if that's if if i had the choice to
know and to not know of course that
would be an advantage but i've been
offered that before in my career
and i've passed on simply because it's
like unpredictable sometimes they get it
wrong
sometimes they they they guess the wrong
pitch and then all of a sudden you're
taking a strike down the middle and
you're thinking to yourself well i can't
i can't deal with this randomness
a pitcher has a tell though what do you
do with that
you take advantage okay but when's the
last time you had
do you share it with your teammates when
you go hey when he does this with his
glove
he's throwing fastball we i mean we all
do that that's that's a tell that's
that's
that's okay of course that's okay yeah
i mean you're not gonna be oblivious to
something that's clear in your face
give me somebody who's retired that had
a tell
somebody that's retired that had to tell
um i don't i don't i don't
think i remember uh randy johnson had to
tell
um if he thought you knew what was
coming
he would hit you so that was his tale
so that would that's probably that's pro
that's a tell that's a tell from randy
johnson he'd hit you
happily we'll wait for the home run
yeah we'll be tuning in and the shout
out
yes uh it's great to talk to you again
and have yourself a lovely day thanks
for having me thank you buddy
that's uh joey votto the reds first
baseman six-time all-star
in uh 2010 actually got vp